let's do this
your weapon will definitely
[Music]
the ramdao
the ram dao is a sacrificial sword that
descends from the weapons of india's
legendary rajput warriors its broad
heavy blade flares to an axe-like
projection which is ideally suited to
the ritual beheading of large animals
such as buffalo and goats these
sacrifices were made to the hindu
goddess of death khali whose symbolic
eye is often etched on the flared end of
the blade so she can watch over the
ceremony the eye of kali can be seen on
the ram dao wielded by zod in a comic
series berserk
good luck blade smiths we'll see you in
four days
[Music]
my name is josh navarrete i was born in
mexico and we came to the united states
when i was a kid this is going to be a
huge challenge there's going to be tears
sweat and probably blood
but i want to go so far we got the basic
profile done
everything ready for quenching
hopefully it worked
yeah
i've never done finial
this was definitely very challenging i
went with a diamond looking piece but no
matter how beautiful the blade is
if you miss one of the parameters
you're out of the competition
my name is ben spangler when i was 15 i
was hanging out on my parents farm and i
found a bucket of blacksmithing tools i
figured let's give it a shot and i liked
it so much i kept doing it ever since so
what i'm gonna try and do first is
throwing out the tang i'm gonna do a
through tang
oh here it goes
boom
this is
my
homemade belt grinder
and this is how i have to start this
thing
i'm just getting to work on the finial
after some light sanding it's gonna be
done
so
i'm ready to go cut something
that's sharp
bladesmiths welcome to the kill test
ram dao
ram carcass
josh you're up first you ready for this
well let's skill it again
oh my god
all right josh let's talk about your ram
dao here the blade you have here is
sharp for every pass it makes it cuts
deeply but i also love what you have
here in sense of balance that even
though it's a chopper the recovery is
just comfortable enough to where you can
cut all the way through it feels good in
the hand it's got a great balance and
most importantly
it will kill
that's awesome thank you
all right then it's your turn you ready
for this i'm excited let's do it
something's off about this design
[Music]
it's part of the parameter it's part of
the design i don't know what's going on
ben your blade doesn't have a finial
ball it's one of the defining
characteristics of the ram dow it was
also one of the parameters and the
judges feel that your blade cannot be
tested evenly and fairly with josh's
please leave the forge
josh congratulations you're the forest
and fire champion and that's a title
that comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars come on forward and shake our
hands brother
i cannot believe this is happening
i think what i'm going to do with ten
thousand dollars is gonna go to open a
shop where i'm gonna be providing
workshops for at-risk youth
the hattori hanzo a thousand layer
katana
whoa born in 16th century japan hattori
hanzo also known as devil hanzo was
perhaps the most legendary samurai to
ever live almost 400 years later in the
2003 tarantino cult classic kill bill
hattori hanzo was reimagined as the
modern-day bladesmith who creates a
katana so fine it would cut god
in reality the katana is the majestic
symbol of the ancient warrior samurai
featuring a simple but elegant single
edge blade designed for precise cuts and
lightning fast thrusts
the dazzling damascus layering produces
not only a beautiful piece of steel but
an incredibly sharp and deadly cutting
edge
good luck blade smiths we'll see you in
five days
let's do this man all right
my name is mike dybert i am a journeyman
bladesmith and an elementary school
teacher i teach spanish and reading
there's a lot of love i pour into it but
that two months in the summer time
blade smithing is a really good therapy
grinding with the grinder i am truly
blessed to have a press and a power
hammer by hand this is very difficult
the blade has a slight warp in it but
it's something that can be ground out so
i'm really happy right now i have my
blade ready now i just need to start
making all the handle parts
this handle has to be tight this sword
is going to be beat up
so now it's going to be wrapped in
stingray skin and ito cord
i'm pretty happy with it
my name is tristan nguyen i'm 19. on a
typical day in tristan land i work in a
pizza shop and i'm studying to be a chef
i kind of pull my inspiration from
everything around me if i see something
in a video game that i really like i'll
try to make it in real life i'm going to
start by working on my 1000 layer
damascus
if i had power tools i feel like i could
have pumped this out a lot faster it's
taking forever in order to get the
weight that i need to be able to get the
sword to length i forge welded mild
steel to the back and the sides of it i
think it'll make the blade
stronger i'm doing the heat treat on my
katana with charcoal and i'm pretty
nervous
this is the make or break moment if
anything goes wrong
i won't be able to finish this piece
straight
my biggest deviation from the tradition
is i'm using shoelaces for my wrap it
just feels the nicest
but their shoelaces
yeah everything feels really together
let's go hit things
[Music]
bladesmiths
hanzos katanas first duty is to kill
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do i will take your
katana and deliver killing blows on this
ballistics dummy
all right mike can you up first are you
ready yes sir students
[Music]
[Music]
yes
mike your edge is razor sharp
but more importantly there's bone on
your edge
but your edge did not roll did not chip
and
your blade stayed true
overall sir
your blade
will kill
thank you
justin you ready yes sir let's do this
hmm
ah
right tristan
the balance of your blade is very good
it's light it's fast it's easily
maneuverable
but
when steel meets the skull there were
some problems
your blade the casirius bend
also on the edge right here you took
some chipping
but overall
looking at the dummy
i think your weapon will definitely kill
thank you
gentlemen
the second duty of a hanzo katana is
that it is to be sharp
it is said that the hanzo katana is as
sharp as a thousand razor blades
now a sharp blade should cut clean
through tatami mats
a dull blade will crush bend or get hung
up a doll blade
is not a hanzo katana
mike you're up first you ready for this
yes i'm ready
your blade sir is sharp it cut cleaning
to the thickest of our tatami mats but
on the back end slice it did not cut
completely though overall sir
your sword will cut
thank you
tristan your turn you ready ready as
i'll ever be sir
[Music]
sorry
well tristan your edge is sharp
you can cut through the tummy mats
my concern
is the strength of your blade
it picked up another bend
now you have two bends on your blade
especially right here close to the guard
tristan this hollywood competition has
been exciting and dramatic you've been
at the epicenter
of all of that drama
nobody is questioning the strength of
your character however
the strength of your blade is such that
we can no longer continue to test it
for that reason i have to ask you to
please leave the forge
mike you were an unstoppable force in
this competition and your atari hanzo
thousand-layer katana is absolutely
deadly earning you the title of forged
and fire champion and a check for 10
grand good job brother i am forged in
fire champion and it feels awesome
[Music]
blackbeard's infamous cutlass
[Music]
among the most notorious pirates of the
18th century blackbeard terrorized
caribbean and atlantic merchant shipping
with his trademark cutlass in hand its
short but thick curved blade featured a
razor sharp edge that was ideal for
hacking and slashing during close
quarters combat while seizing small
vessels in his legendary battle with
captain robert maynard in 1718
blackbeard's cutlass broke maynard sword
in half with a single blow
today blackbeard's menacing presence and
expert swordmanship can still be seen in
the video game assassin's creed iv black
flag
good luck we'll see you in five days
my name is seth marshall fortune's an
escape to where i can feel accomplished
in something that i've done
i like my knives like i like my eyebrow
thicken in one piece
i'm gonna make sure the handles aren't
too big but they're not too small
because there will be multiple operators
it's a lot of steel to be putting on a
handle
yeah
i want to do a
robust edge on it i want to keep it
thick so it doesn't get broken up so
easily
i like it
[Music]
my sword is all together it's all one
piece now
it's a cutlass it's blackbeard's cutlass
heavy
yes
my name is jason crum
at night i'm a bladesmith but during the
day i host a morning radio show when i
meet people they go hey talk in your
radio voice and this is it this is me
but they want me to say something like
hey hey guys and gals kids games welcome
to the show i have no press no power
hammers uh my power hammers
look at that huh that this is the
problem you get an arm like that and one
like that the plan is to take it one
piece at a time and forge it as if i was
forging a jigsaw puzzle even though it's
gonna be cheesy and campy i'm making the
clam shell guard look like clam shells
putting the jigsaw puzzle with my handle
together went really well i put a little
skull face on the back there
i'm gonna leave the edge geometry just a
little beefier just so it can stand up
to some of the brutal chopping that it's
probably gonna see he stole me pirate
booty
and now you're paying the price
[Music]
it will kill
blade smith to test the lethality of
your cutlass i'm going to inflict lethal
wounds on these ballistic dummies
jason you are first you ready i sure
hope so doug let's do this
[Music]
all right jason you got a very big
handle here but at least it's got the
swells it's got an indexing to where i
hold on to it i can tell where the edge
is
the weight that you have in this weapon
is so light incense that i can wield it
even around here you cut the clavicle
into the ribs all the way through the
lungs
and definitely it will kill
all i ever wanted to hear made my day
seth you're up next are you ready get
some
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right seth your sword is forward
heavy without a balance coming back i
don't know the shoulder's going to hurt
more the dummies are mine
but your weapon sir will kill
thank you
assess the strength and durability of
your swords i'll be chopping through
these bones and then attacking that peg
leg now remember this test is not about
what your blades do to these targets
it's about what these targets do to your
blades
jason you're up are you ready nope
oh
[Music]
the balance of your weapon
is really nice
which is surprising because you've made
a two-handed cutlass
your blade
held up very well except for the one
little chip and it's not even chipped to
roll
so it didn't blow out it's good job
thank you dave
all right seth are you ready yes sir
all right seth
first up
this thing's a beast
it is probably a pound heavier than your
competitor's sword
your blade
i mean i can run my finger to inhale
down this i can see a couple of glinting
spots but it really didn't take any
damage
all right bladesmiths let's find out if
there's any edge left this is the rope
cut and pirate sail slash to test the
edge of your cutlass i will cut this
rope which will raise the sail and then
i will slash the sail
this is all about what your sword will
do to the sail and rope
chasing you up first ready yes sir
[Music]
all righty jason your edge cut through
the rope easily and cuts with every part
that the edge met on this pirate sail
overall sir your sword will cut
awesome
seth how you feeling
feel good let's go let's do this
[Music]
all right seth
what are the chances you find a very
dull spot on the first cut on the rope
but on the second cut it found another
spot that was sharp but on the sail
working a heavy sword like this affects
my cuts
jason seth the judges have tested your
weapons and they've made a final
decision
our new forged and fire champion is
jason
congratulations you're the new fortune
fire champion
seth unfortunately your blade did not
make the cut please surrender your blade
jason congratulations you are our new
forging fire champion and that's a title
that comes with a bundle of bullion
that's worth 10 grand how you feeling
right now
come on
that's incredible fortune fire champion
the celtic anthropomorphic sword
the celtic anthropomorphic sword is an
iron age weapon that's both elegant and
lethal it boasts a distinctive hilt
displaying anthropomorphic meaning
human-like features often cast from
bronze
fearsome killer that the sword's strong
double-edged point can be used as a
deadly thruster as well as a swift
slasher capable of quick attacks and
close quarters combat a classic of iron
age celtic weaponry the sword battles on
in popular culture including the 2011
historical drama the eagle
good luck bladesmiths we'll see you in
five days good luck
my name is bill benke i'm from kingsley
michigan i'm 71 years old i've been
forging for about 40 years now
i've watched the show quite a bit and i
thought i could do that so this is my
test
time will tell
the first thing i got to do today is get
my steel cut for the damascus i want to
try for a high layer count something
that makes the steel look shimmery in
the light that's a big building
i need to get the gases done the only
thing i can think of is making like a
cookie pattern
[Music]
success
i put an african black wood handle on to
it so i hope it kind of matches the
darkness that's in the damascus i know
it'll cut
i got two band-aids to prove it
right here
my name is chuck fowler i'm from
interlaken florida
i'm
47 or 48 years old i can't remember grew
up in a blade smithing shop my father's
been a bladesmith since i was a kid i
really want to do this competition to
see if i can actually compete
and my wife and kids wanted me to do it
i'm going to have to get each billet
welded up and then incorporate both
those billets together in order to get
enough length and width to make the
sword i grabbed a big chunk of 4041 got
the blade completely forged i've decided
to cast directly onto my tang i capture
the details and the handle that i want
to capture it should look pretty cool
yep some of the casting was lost i don't
know what happened i've got to cast this
bronze handle one more time i am going
to try it vertical this time i'm going
to finish filling this up tamp it down
if it don't work this time that's it in
theory i could actually bury the handle
deep enough
to where the molten bronze would go down
and have nowhere to escape and go around
the tang
i just don't have enough time to cast
another bronze handle
what enough
looks like
i'm over it all this
work for nothing my second attempt at
casting is the bust i'm done i am done
no more where i'm ready to just quit i'm
not going to complete the sword at all
but then i got to think about bill it
wouldn't be fair to him so i continue on
i want to get a completed sword up there
so i'm just going to do it my way make
it look as good as i can
i had a lot of issues these past five
days i pushed through and i'm glad i got
it done
this is the kill test to see what kind
of lethal damage your sword will do i
will take your weapon and deliver
killing blows on this ram carcass
bill ready for the kill
yes i am
man
that's my sharp sword right bill let's
talk about your blade right here first
up your handle feels good it's got a
nice shape to it that just fits nicely i
like the guard i like the bronze that
you have right there i can immediately
tell where the edge is
this is what i don't like about your
blade
it doesn't allow me to have fun two hits
it's done
this is really light fast and sharp bill
it will kill thank you
all right chuck it's your turn you ready
yes sir let's do this i'm feeling a
little anxious
what are you thinking right now
oh that's a lot of weight man
chuck
doug's taking a look at your sword
it's just too heavy to wield safely the
parameter specifically called for a
sword that was light enough to wield
one-handed because your blade failed to
meet the parameters
i have to ask you to please leave the
forge
well bill you are now our new forged and
fire champion it's a title that comes
with a check for ten thousand dollars
thanks thanks very much i'm the forging
fire champion whoo
the glaive gizon
what
oh
commonly seen on battlefields during the
medieval era the glaive geez alm was one
of the principal weapons for european
foot soldiers in combat this fearsome
pole arm evolved from the celtic and
german custom of attaching swords or
edged weapons to the end of long wooden
poles
the combination of the long convex blade
mounted to a wooden shaft was ideal for
combatting enemies on horseback due to
its reach and versatility the glaive
gesome had a signature hook or spike on
the opposite side of blade to catch
riders and move enemy pikes
cheap to produce and deadly against
cavalry the glade gesund was essential
on the battlefield for hundreds of years
until it was phased out in the 18th
century
good luck blade smiths you're gonna need
it we'll see you in five days
my name is alex eisenberg i'm 29 years
old i own a tattoo shop and am a
full-time tattoo artist as well as
bladesmith most of my tattoos are a
representation of something that's
happened to me and the rest of them are
just stuff that i thought was cool and i
liked and i said i want that one the
steel i've chosen to make the socket out
of is just a regular mild steel pipe my
uh weapon is too long
for either oven and i want to make sure
i get a good heat treat so we are
running dueling ovens
there we go
all right good
preparing the wood to be inserted into
the socket i've left it pretty snug so
it's gonna be a hammer fit i've
completed my weapon and i feel great
about it i put my best forward and i
left it all out there
i'm excited to see what it does and i
think it'll do well
[Music]
my name is nick santella i am 39 years
old and i
am a geologist i would say that being a
geologist i do have a little extra
insight in the materials not that i have
a very technical approach to
blacksmithing i'm more
pound away see what happens
my shop is a pretty traditional setup
oh i'm still not quite getting the kind
of heat i'd like i need a bigger blower
and the biggest blower that i've got is
a shock vacuum well this is exactly what
they always tell you not to do so
[Music]
that's what i'm talking about
but it's not taking a whole lot of time
for me to wear out
it'd be easier with a uh big burly man
to strike for me
i'm gonna call that good
i know it's a critical parameter to make
sure that the head doesn't come loose
but i'm getting pretty impatient i think
that's good enough
i would definitely do it different and
better if i were to do it again but you
know for here and now i'm pretty happy
with it
well it prunes
to see what kind of lethal damage your
weapon will do i'll take your glaze on
deliver thrust and slashes on this deer
carcass nicky up first you ready
guess so let's do this
first up right here on your edge it
picked up a chip
on another side of this you can feel
where the edge also rolled
but this weapon is sharp on the initial
thrust it's got a geometry right there
that penetrated deep into the carcass
your edge right here on slashing it
lacerated easily on the side of this
deer carcass on the third cut the weight
of this weapon is so balanced it's easy
to lacerate all the way through
your weapon will kill
thank you
all right alex your turn
all right alex your tip
is sharp enough to lacerate all the way
through on the slash of this edge it's
lacerated easily
on the side rib of this particular
carcass
on the wide swing
it did break half of the spine off it is
as you can see a little bit on the wider
side and the heavy weapon like this a
wide handle can make it hard to control
yeah but the most important thing
it will kill thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test the pike chop
that was intense i wasn't ready for that
often in pike warfare the glaives or
weapons like them are used as a
secondary line of defense to push the
pike up out of the way and or to chop at
the pike shaft so to test the strength
and durability of your weapons including
the hook on the back i'll be pushing
these pikes up into position then
chopping at them with the blades all
right nick you're up first you ready yes
sir
[Music]
i'd say that's pretty good
all right so nick it doesn't look like
your weapon took any more damage to the
edge the weight of your blade is very
nicely balanced it's a good design
definitely a strong blade nicely done
thank you
alex you ready yes sir
don't break it be nice
that was brutal dude
first off your blade did take some
damage here they're very small chips and
rolls
your flanges here are just wide enough
that when i pushed forward i managed to
grab two rows of pikes and push them
back at the same time balance is nice on
it the shaft is pretty wide it's not too
big but it's right on the outside edge
of what's comfortable for my hand but
everything held up everything's solid
thank you all right gentlemen now it's
time for the sharpness test to test the
sharpness of your blade i'll be cutting
these ropes now that releases the bag
and i'll be cutting the bag now unlike
the strength test this is all about what
your weapons do to these targets
nick you're up first you ready
that's pretty cool yeah
well nick cut through the bags really
cleanly and what i really like is the
balance of this weapon it's very easy to
maneuver it didn't have to fight the
weapon nicely done thank you all right
alex you're up you ready yes sir
[Music]
all right
your blade is wicked sharp
this passed right through the rope with
very little resistance at all and it cut
the bags beautifully the balance of your
blade is a little bit more to the tip
so the one thing about this blade when i
cut with it is slowing it down after the
cut but uh it's a beautiful cutter did a
great job thank you
nick alex you've both done an incredible
amount of work on your finale weapons
however there can only be one forged and
fire champion and that champion is
nick
congratulations you are our next forage
and fire champion
alex please surrender your blade
nick congratulations you are our new
forged and fire champion and that's a
title that comes with a check for 10
grand good job
i got to make some really cool stuff
meet some really cool people and be a
champion that's just a really cool bonus
you